[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами сьогодні пані Соля
та наша дорогеньке довгождане знання
зовеля сьогодні дуже молодець бо Не
спізнилося правильно Так я геть не
спізнився
Отож Давайте ми сьогодні з вами будемо
говорити про щось дуже цікаве знаєте про
що ми будемо говорити про сніг Та й
загалом про воду так сьогодні поговоримо
про сніг і різні цікавинки про воду щоб
ви знали друзі і ми сьогодні про це вам
розповімо Вода перебуває у трьох станах
що таке три стани бо це якби у нас було
три Совеня різної форми і всі ці три
Совеня було би тобою
Ого То як одна і та ж Вода може бути
різною так друзі одна і теж вода може
бути дуже різною і ми зараз з вами про
це поговоримо детальніше
ше з того що я тут маю такий
мішечок з камінцями буду вам показувати
різні камінці А ви будьте казати Яка це
погода на вашу думку
Отож тут у нас є намальована
крапля що це крапля може означати яка це
може бути погода так Друзі бо падає
дощик правда покажемо крап-крап
крап-крап крап маленький дощик А тепер
давайте покажемо великий дощик крап
крапка А тепер цілу Злива Злива Злива
Злива Злива Злива Злива молодці далі
ось цей Камінець при яку погоду нам каже
так друзі що падає сніг
добре а тепер скажіть мені будь ласка А
ось цей Камінець про яку погоду каже
так малюки що багато хмар Які в нас
бувають хмари давайте пригадаємо
купчасту дощові купчасті та перисті дуже
добре А про що свідчить Ось ця погода
що у нас зараз грім там блискавка дуже
добре
про що свідчить Ось ця погода про те що
світить сонечко молодці і інколи сонечко
закривається чим
хмарками дуже добре друзі Гаразд
Пригадали яка буває погода
Тож давайте поговоримо детально про сніг
чи знали ви друзі що
вода перебуває у трьох станах ці три
стани називаються рідина газ і твердий
лід рідина - це той стан води який ми
всі знаємо Так ми п'ємо воду газ - це
такий стан коли наприклад
парує чайник Так коли ми його ставимо на
гарячий чай і ось ця пара яка виходить
Коли парує чайник або наприклад ми
варимо супчик є іншим станом води
і твердий лід - Це або лід або наш
сніжок так і сніжинки які ми бачимо коли
вони падають
все іншими словами є водою
Зараз ми поговоримо детально про
сніжинки і про сніг чи знаєте ви друзі
що кожна сніжиночка яку ви бачите є
абсолютно і інша від будь-якої іншої
сніжинки всі сніжинки є надзвичайно
різні і ще ніколи не повторювалися
жодної однакової сніжинки ось тут на
зображенні в нас є одні сніжинки А ось
тут зблизька сфотографовано інша
сніжинка і всі-всі-всі сніжинки які ми
бачимо є
абсолютно іншими і відрізняються одна
від одної якщо ви якось взимку вийдете
на вулицю коли падає сніг поставити
долоньку з рукавичкою і побачити як на
ручку падає сніжинка кожна нова сніжинка
буде відрізнятися від попередньої Отож
у різних станах давайте ще раз повторимо
пара
так І ми його можемо дуже часто бачити
Коли
кип'ятимо чайник або ж цей стан пара або
газ перебуває у вигляді
коли піднімається до хмарок пригадуєте
ви вчили про кругообіг води в природі і
я казала про те що коли вода
піднімається ми її зовсім не бачимо вона
Такі маленькі маленькі
кристалики піднімаються Та хмарок це
власне і є цей стан газу про який ми
говоримо інший стан - це є вода і третій
- це є лід або сніг
також
якщо ми беремо
різну температуру то ми можемо
перетворити нашу воду у різні стани і
навпаки Наприклад якщо у нас є кубики
льоду і ми їх
розігріємо тому що купити льоду
перетворюється
[музика]
добре малюки у воду а якщо візьму воду і
заморозимо тому що перетвориться вода
правильно в кубики льоду також друзі
пригадуєте наше заняття про молоко і ми
з вами говорили що з сир утворюється з
молока то якщо молоко нагріте під
спеціальними температурами то може бути
не лише гарячим молоко а й сир тобто
твердий стан та як в нас є лід твердий
стан води так і сир твердий стан молока
Ось так Друзі а тепер друзі Давайте я
вам скажу чому виблискує сніг Ось так ми
йдемо в якийсь день і бачимо або під
сонцем під місяцем блищить сніг і ніц в
жодному разі не є якісь дорогоцінні
каміннячка чи кристали це насправді
просто маленькі сніжинки відбивають
місячне або сонячне світло неначе
малесенькі дзеркальця і відповідно нам
здається що сніг виблискує ніби
коштовності а насправді Це просто
сніжинки як Люстерка відбивають світло
від місяця або від сонця і вони
потрапляють у наша око Ось така
цікавинка ще одна цікавинка друзі чому
під ногами рипить сніг Ось так ми йдемо
з вами і він рип рип рип рип насправді
це відбувається не завжди взимку але
лише тоді коли є певна температура на
дворі температура має бути нижчою ніж
-2°. слово друзі це коли вже так холодно
і трішки знаєте Морозець щипає за щічки
треба одягати Рукавичка і вже її досить
холодно при такій температурі
кристалики льоду малесенькі матеріали
які є у наших сніжинках
розпадаються під нашими ногами і тому ми
чуємо такий звук коли температура є
вищою трішки теплішою тоді ці кристалики
не розпадаються а просто ковзають і
тануть в нас під ногами Ось так друзі ми
будемо сьогодні з вами завершувати я
сподіваюся ну було цікаво і ви не
змерзли від розмов про сніг гукаємо наше
словеня Ану скуштують ручки Совеня А ну
ще раз боє зовсім не чую для чую Ну ще
раз А тепер тихіше А тепер гучніше
чудово Я думаю Совеня летить там щось
тріпоче крильми дрібочок рильми крильми
тріпочу і головою тріпочу і до вас Я
прилетів Ух
так Друзі Ну будемо завершувати Мені
дуже сподобалося дізнатися що вода
перебуває у трьох станах Совеня в трьох
станах не перебуває а вода перебуває
дуже-дуже цікаво
будемо з вами прощатися давайте
помахайте мені ручкою А тепер помахайте
тільки пальчиками А тепер знову ручкою А
тепер знову пальчиками А я помахаю
крильцями і буду казати вам па-па
па-па друзі до наступного разу
Привіт друзі Всім привіт з вами
науковиця Соломія
частинка Ми сьогодні експериментуємо
правильно
добре Ви готові друзі і ми готові
в нас сьогодні є
кукурудзяний Крохмаль це такий
порошочок який використовується для
випічки хтось в косметиці Здається це
використовується для якихось кремчиків
ну слово
для випічки так ще у нас є мило рідке
мило
Мишка і
так Давай юстинко наливай мило окей
треба буде нам трохи багато
багато-багато механі пальців
спортивне заняття для пальчиків
Добре тепер давай Ми достимемо сюди
крохмаль бачите він виглядає як
борошно як сніг як борошно і давай
останку пробуємо перемішувати як в разі
чого я ще додам
Так ми трохи перемішали ложку А я тепер
спробую перемішати пальцями Так
перемішуємо
я думаю що так знаєте друзі це як от ми
робимо тісто і Якщо нам здається що
трохи
[музика]
коли ми робимо тісто і нам здається що
наприклад ми замало додали
яєць молока або води і наприклад борошно
погано чіпляється до купи так тоді нам
треба додати ще Окей що в нас вийшло
друзі Ви можете так спостерігати думати
що та пані солі з юстинкою роблять Що
вони придумали А в нас вийшов штучний
сніг
слово в нас вийшов штучний сніг якщо от
можна з нього ліпити різні фігурки можна
ліпити сніжки можна навіть зліпити
сніговичка
або іншими словами у нас вийшов слайм
правда друзі Ви знаєте що таке слайм
слайм часто любить чіплятися до одягу і
потім Його неможливо відчистити правда
от А оце такий знаєте корисний слайм
який шкоди для нашого одягу не зробить
От і з нього також можна щось робити
істинку Що я зробила кульку зробила так
і потім після того коли ти до нього
доторкнешся дуже гладенькі пальчик можна
собі зробити якісь кульки і він дуже
приємний на дотик знаєте це як є такі
іграшки називаються антистрес
випадку собі сидиш розминаєш в ручках
про щось собі міркуєш і паралельно і
мрії і мрієш наприклад Та от це у нас
приблизно щось таке і вийшло воно
приємне дотик
зовсім не шкідливе на хімічне і ви
можете спробувати теж зробити собі такий
слайм або штучний сніг наприклад влітку
коли вам захочеться погратися снігом
замість мела рідкого також може бути
гель для душу шампуні або
рідина для миття посуду Ось так а не
обов'язково
оранчеве мило використовувати До речі ви
можете навіть додати наприклад
якусь фарбу або
барвник і відповідно У вас можуть бути
різного кольору такі
сніжки Я вже робила штучний сніг білий
але ще фарби додала і були кольорові
крапельки
сніжок Ось так Друзі на цьому наш
експеримент закінчився і нам треба
закінчувати тому що ми тут трохи
забавилися наробили базову треба
поприбирати
ось запам'ятайте якщо ви робите якісь
речі Треба перенести ремонтуйте після
себе треба обов'язково все пробирати
домовитись Та мало листя Ну що ж всім
Гарного дня па-па па-па
[музика]